Chinese swimmer Ye Shiwen has continued her startling rise to glory by taking her second gold at London 2012...
...in the 200 meters individual medley.
And like any superstar, Ye is attracting quite a following amongst swimmers in her home nation.
I like swimming.
I want to be like big brother Sun Yang and big sister Ye Shiwen and do the Olympics.
I'm very jealous of them.
Some fans however are upset at the controversy surrounding the superpower's new super swimmer.
We feel very angry that a small number of people in the West would say this about young Chinese swimmer Ye Shiwen.
They're being so irresponsible.
Our young girl relied on her perseverance and talents to gain glory for the country and to win the race.
We're very angry over what certain people in the West said.
Either way, the goals, aspirations, and performances of one young girl thousand of miles from home...
...are set to inspire a generation.